hello everyone
um yes today I'm going I want to have a
talk about ultimate what it is uh it's
not just because I'm lazy to write
networks by myself
um it's more about because I want to
effectively use my time and I think
everyone wants to do the same
so today what I will talk about what is
Ultimate
um then I will show you where do we
actually have automl in AWS and I want
to
spend a little bit like 10 or maybe five
cents five seven minutes for two
Services which is like AWS services
available for everyone and then the the
biggest part of my talk I want to spend
on autoglyon which is open source
Library created by Amazon and that
library is specifically designed for
automl
so what is automl
um
when we're talking about machine
learning we always say that it's quite
simple just bring your data select
algorithm and you know have fun make
predictions
that's actually true so those three
steps are most important one but inside
each step usually have like sub steps
and they could be like 10 20 sub steps
um for example if we're talking about
the data there will be data augmentation
data cleaning data analysis
visualization and many different steps
if we are talking about algorithms
um first of all you need to selected
algorithm probably you will need to test
like 10 20 algorithms to select one of
them and then you will tune each
algorithm and even when you move to
production it's also not so easy because
every model could be like different size
you probably have some kind of SLA or
for the latency of your model so you'll
try to optimize your model maybe you
need to distill your model maybe need to
retrain optimize
serving server optimized software stack
on which you're running a model so
actually that's not really as simple as
it looks like
and that that's why
you know the software development is
here for a really long time
the same ideas about automation is also
applied for machine learning and we're
talking about automation I'm talking
about every disposable steps so there
might be automation of data preparation
algorithm selection algorithm tuning
moving into production optimizing the
final model so every step could be
automated but it doesn't mean that we
always have to automate all steps maybe
we can automate just part of them
so that's why I actually in AWS we have
really big variety of services just for
machine learning
and depending on on the level
there will be more or less automation so
for example here where we have just
virtual machines that is just minimum of
automation we are automatically gives
you the virtual machine that's it then
you do everything by yourself
but on the top layer we have services
that almost automate everything so for
example like uh my my my personal office
Amazon forecast because I really love
forecasting time series problems so in
this service you just bring your data as
a CSV file and that's it and you get a
model for the forecasting it could be
used for any kind of problem or
forecasting like demand forecasting
inventory planning
um in some services like recognition you
even don't need to bring a data there is
already a model which is automatically
retraining for everyone and to use that
service you just need to know what is it
python or any other programming language
but today I want to talk more about
services that actually require some
some actions at least so the first one
the first one is a sagemaker canvas
that Source was designed for people who
mostly working as a business analyst so
who wants to use machine learning but
don't want to put their hands in machine
learning
so that is quite simple we we automate
everything and we actually bring really
nice UI so it's independent from AWS
console if you see it if you saw with
the Boost console uh especially if you
saw things like sagemaker console uh
it's more like
machine learning it's Jupiter lab you
work in there but in the sagemake
accounts we have separate uis really
super friendly just few buttons uh and
you can actually log in it without
asking AWS console so you can just you
know give it to business analysis and
they could use it so you you could bring
your data it could be just uploaded from
a local computer it could be used
directly from other services like S3
redshift which is a day which is a data
warehouse you can you can even use
snowflake which is third party solution
to ingest the data then you can play
with the data a little bit to analyze so
we automatically generate like even like
graphs so you can analyze what kind of
data you have
and then you could just train your model
and actually to train the model you just
press one button you select how you want
to train like you do want to have fast
train and you have you want to have
normal train and then we are training
your models actually on the back end we
are doing things like future
futurization the future selection
training of many different algorithms
we're optimizing hyper parameters and
they will just bring you like here's
your best model
the the metrics like accuracy graphs
like growth row on the curve so there
are many different things and many
different graphs that Services could be
used for things like
regression problem classification
problem and time forecasting problem
yeah it's super easy to use you don't
need to do anything if you want then you
could just select your model and share
it with a data scientist scheme who have
an access to the
let's say more Metro services like
sagemaker so they could actually play to
help you to optimize your model and then
at the end you could make just one
prediction if you will put it manually
like all values or you can just use it
for a batch inference so you provide
your file and we give you back to all
all inferences for that file that's it
that's super easy to use
that was the first service
Second Source which I want to highlight
today is autopilot so it's the same idea
we want to automate as much as possible
but still give you some at least an
option to control what what is going on
the area is also is in the canvas just
bring the data run the autopilot and if
you want deploy the model and get the
predictions but
on the back end so actually what will
happen so it's super easy to use you
just
press one button again
uh in the back end we will automatically
analyze your data we'll train in many
algorithms human hyper parameters for
them and we will select the best model
for you
but in a comparison to the previous the
account was where it's like a black box
here we will also generate three
notebooks for you so the first notebook
will be data exploration
we will show you all problems with your
data like missing data too much
duplicated data so we will analyze that
and we'll give you an outbook with exact
you know with all all of our findings in
your data
the second notebook will be about how we
train the models so we'll show you all
models that we trained all algorithms
all parameters will give you the final
leaderboard of all those combinations so
you can see how exactly we made the
decision about the best model
um yeah the third notebook I will show
you later so that's how a exploration
notebook looks like so we give you like
your the samples of your data and we'll
give you the feedback row row wise on
column wise what's happening
um yeah so you can select
okay that's that's good question so
first of all you could select if you
want in in advance it but by default we
will try to understand that because like
if you have just two three possible
values in a Target column that's
probably classification if you have big
variety that's a this is a regression so
it's quite simple
yeah so then we'll give you the notebook
with a possible candidates like all
algorithms all high parameters
everything will be available for you so
actually you then you can just take that
data and you know train whatever you
want in laborers outside of AWS it's
really up to you and the last notebook
will be about future importance so we'll
calculate future importance for all for
the best model so you can get a little
bit of yes that's based on shop value so
you'll get an understanding which
attributes were most
influence on the final decision
for example for example for
classification
yeah I don't think I don't remember
exactly
um
it's publicly available on the website
you know I could open it on my cell
phone we can take of it so it's not a
secret I just do not remember I'm not
using that a lot in my daily daily work
um yeah so those were Services which
were designed to run things fully
automatically in first case you do
nothing at all and second case you have
a visibility of what's going on
so it's included so it's like we're just
doing that for you
um in sagemaker there is a company
that's specifically designed for that
it's called sagemaker clarify and
autopilot is just using that component
to calculate so that's a topic when I
want to spend more time because we own a
pi data not AWS Summit
um the outer glion is a automl library
designed by Amazon and published to the
open source so it's available for
everyone you can use it
uh yeah as I said that's a toolkit that
specifically designed for machine
modeling and the idea was to help people
to start using machine learning so
it works for uh things like it works
with the text Data it works with the
image data it takes it works with a
tabular data it's it could actually
works with a multi-model data it means
that in some problems you might have
text images
and tabular data together and instead of
working with them separately we're
actually proposing you to start to work
them together in the same time
um and yeah I didn't mention here that
we also started to support time series
data so it also could work for
forecasting problem
as I said it's open source you can
install with a prep install Auto glion
um yes and it's actually could tune have
a parameters but that's not the secret
source of that thing uh the most
important one is a model ansembling and
I will show you exactly how it works
so yes if you want there is a website
autoglion AI which have a really nice
documentation examples quick starts and
all that things if you want to take a
look what's inside all source code is
publicly available on our official git
wrap-on
um yeah if you'll if you'll start to
look you probably will find that we also
have a glion TS which are gliontyne
series we also have glion tabular but
all those projects and now I could say
used by autoglio so you can use each of
them independently or you can just use
Auto glion and it will be used
automatically
okay so but what what was previously
mostly
how previously automl Works uh in a
couple of previous years so mostly when
people saying out email it was it was
that we have just bunch of algorithms we
have hyper parameters for them and we
were just you know trying to find which
have a parameter which algorithm will
make a best model
so we just actually we're like training
thousands of models and just select one
of them uh that was previous approach
for uh automl
we decided to change that and actually
Auto glion is focusing on several steps
so first of all it's data pre-processing
so Auto Glen automatically analyze the
data which we provided so he is
selecting attribution selection features
then he is also
using multi-layer model stacking to
create a model for you
uh we also use different deploying
techniques for sure we're using simple
algorithms but we're also using really
really good really deep learning
algorithms
um and there are many different things I
will highlight some of them today but if
you really want to understand all the
powerful of the auto million you need to
take a look on the documentation or at
least some more videos that you can find
so coming back to the previous
previous discussion what was the hyper
parameter optimization job so actually
you just have as I said hyper parameters
and you have algorithms and just start
to train
um different combinations of them there
were several techniques like green
search random search whereas in
optimization but the idea was that you
trained thousands of models then you
select just one of them and you just
drop off the rest of
999 models that was really not actually
still the way of people doing that today
and actually that's a really big waste
of resources so you're actually just
taking less than one percent of the of
the training models
um I'm pretty sure that you heard about
random forest and how how it works just
that just to repeat it for you so there
is a there is algorithm called decision
tree it's simple you just asking
questions and trying to divide data
based on
um data gain and then someone designed
at random forest and the idea of random
words was really simple instead of
building single model let's build 10 of
the model but with a random set of the
data all those models will be really
simple and they were all wrong but if we
will average them they actually becomes
more powerful than a single model even
optimized that was the idea of the
random forest and it's quite easy to you
know to describe how it works so if we
will take our data and that there is one
X and Y and we're trying to predict the
color
the random for uh sorry the the decision
tree will actually do something like
that so he just draw the boundaries
between the dots and then we will say
that everything which is inside specific
area have that color
that powerful but here is a problem that
this model could not work with the
smallest difference because even you
know the the areas are quite big so
there's no average isn't averaging
um this is how many simple models when
the random datable looks like as you can
see that they looks really the same but
they actually all they're all wrong they
all made they make mistakes but if we'll
take all of them and just average you'll
see something like that
so it becomes more powerful because
there is not so Street borders there is
some averages so predictions become
stronger
yeah that's an idea of um random Forest
it's really simple it's beautiful as I
said all models are wrong inside but
they've wronged in different directions
and when we average them we just help
them to compensate each other that's
called
variance constellation
and we decided
[Music]
um
yeah one refused I learned the story
before that so how actually that idea of
the random Forest started to grow there
were many competitions one of them for
example the next Netflix price
the competition was to beat the Netflix
current model by 10 percent
and it actually tooks like
two years
of many teams to build a such model and
that model inside was builded by 102
separated models
and what what is yes they beat they won
that competition everything was great
but what Netflix Engineers told you know
to them that yes you pay that model you
have really strong model but the effort
to take that your your model into
Productions is so big that we will not
do that so that's a problem so even one
competition you can build really a
strong model but it will be impossible
to repeat it and use it in the real
production when you need to continuously
improve your model
and and that actually that's the way how
many competitions were won there's just
an example of different models so you
can see that there is a model which used
500 models then it used
um 125 models you can imagine that there
is more than one thousand of the models
just to you know solve one task it's
impossible to use it in production
that's nice from a search point of view
but it's not production weight
uh but can we actually you know use the
same approach to build a stable
performance model but with a without
like super tight without super
overfeeding to specific case like make
it really case independent maybe we can
actually use the same idea of answer
link models but without need to you know
to have a knowledge
and maybe we can do that in reasonable
time with a really simple nice API
yes that was autoglion was designed for
so the autoglion used that idea uh if
you actually interesting the yes there
is a link if you want you can just
Google auto glion papers you could find
papers that we wrote so no I'm not an
author and I said we as Amazon we've
wrote
um about the idea of Stack ensembling
but it ideas this one what you should
what you see on the screen so
we're taking different models and if you
will recall the random cut for us use
the same models so it was always
decision tree but we propose to use
different models so let's use Cat books
Edge boost let's use Transformers and
put them all together in one so which
we're just training first layer of the
model then we took outputs of those
models we're concatenating it back to
the initial data set and we are training
that next layer of the models so that's
the way how actually
let's say one model could learn the
output from another model so models
start to share knowledges and this that
was really powerful approach then in the
end we just you know making some waiting
averaging them and you get an output
um
and we could use more than one layer so
if you want you can have like four
layers of such stacking uh it's really
up to you to control it by default we
use one or two but you can you can just
change the parameter during the training
yeah
yeah but it it will I couldn't say that
I saw a lot of time when four or five
layers make some difference
yeah so that's an idea of Stack
ansembling what we're using for as a
basic model when I say basic model I
mean those model one two and then so for
basic models we're using gradient
boosting models like YouTube boost like
GBM catboost we're using several custom
table or neural networks we're also
using things like cycle learn random
Forest X3 KMS we used for images things
like efficient resnet your
for a text we use better electric and
actually we integrated hugging phase so
now we use hugging face models as part
of the auto glion during the training
um but as I said you actually might have
a multi-model problem so when you have
images text and tabular data as as data
for for the same question and instead of
working with them separately we are
proposing to start work with them
together so that's an example of one of
the
possible data set so for example like
you want to predict will be
um well well did that animal taken by
someone or not so we actually have an
image of the animal you have description
and you have some tabular date of the
cat
and you want to predict will someone
take it or not
and for that we that's again you see
that just in images from a paper so it's
interesting you can read it so we
we're just repeating ourselves but
instead of the just simple models like
cat boost extra boost we also start to
use Transformers
like from hanging face like like image
red and that's the way how actually
gradient models started to get
understanding what's going on in the
Transformers model like an output of the
Transformers
um
yes so we we made some tests so those
tests were made in 2020 in this year
there will be nearly I mean we will
release new tests it's on the on the
review right now and for a multi-modal
problem autoglyon 123 from 29 possible
data sets and from 11 data sets we also
one on from 11 2011 data sets in Chicago
we won seven
so as you can see auto Glen is really
powerful thing
um yeah there are some more examples
like we took like second place on
several cargo competitions we took first
place on the mechanical competition but
I want to highlight this one it's Auto
Group we took foreign it's still kind of
muscle it's still really good to have
been put in but um
there is it's place is not really
important the more important than we
took that place with just four hours of
training
while the to beat that results people
spend like two months of working like a
team to do something better than four
hours of how to play on training so as I
said I'm not I'm not lazy I just want to
use my time more effectively if in four
hours I could do the job which usually
took two months that's great you know I
could spend time on something else
and actually to obtain all those results
that I showed we didn't optimize hyper
parameters at all
we just use standard hyper parameters
that auto glion have by default
um and to actually to you to create
those results you just need three lines
of the code so on the first line you
import auto glion as a library and a
python on the second line you just
creating an object predictor and then
you specify parameters like where is the
training data which metric you want to
use which presets you want to use the
process is really important thing uh
presses Define how we will train the
model so there is best quality means it
will be a super good model but it will
takes more time if you want you can use
something like medium quality it will be
like 16 times more
faster to train but it will be less
accurate so actually we have a table in
a documentation of different of all
presets and what kind of you know
difference in training time and quality
you might get by changing them uh let's
say at the beginning you might use
medium just to get you know the first
experience but then you can use best
quality to get the best model
so that's that's it and the last uh last
is the last line is actually is actually
you're using predictor to create
predictions so that's the way how all
those first second places on the goggle
were achieved just with three lines of
the code
if you want then you can use something
like leaderboards or actually if you
want we will you can just use one simple
method and we'll show you all models
that have trained it as a part inside of
during the training and we provide you
things like score test score validation
but we also provide you
um
time
so what is the time
you can imagine that you know every task
have its own SLA which means like for
some task you might wait five minutes or
a other task you don't want to wait five
minutes some from that table you can
also see that for example those two
models uh customer igbm and weighted
ansible so they had quite similar
results yes weighted ansible is better
but the latency is almost 10 times more
so if you're really looking for a low
latency you should select the second
model if you're okay with the with that
latency it's like the best select the
best model which is first one
um it's also capable to calculate future
importance
um
so if you want you can also calculate to
see like which features influence on the
model decision if you want I don't have
it as a screenshot if you want there is
a method which will show you exactly
entire announceable so it will give you
actually it will generate your gpac with
a with an ansible picture if you want to
understand what's going on inside
um yeah so a few things that we I just
want to highlight some recent releases
so the 0.4 was released in March 2020 oh
2022 it becomes more faster and becomes
more faster in inference and becomes
more faster in training and training
because we Implement them to Ray
framework inside of the auto glion so we
use it for a parallel begging
um we also added infinite limits which
is really good parameter if you know
from a beginning that your SLA is like
let's say 300 milliseconds you can from
a beginning put it as a limit and
ultimately on during the training if you
will see that the model already about
that limit he will just stop to train it
and drop that that branch of the models
so he is always trying to optimize based
on your inference limit yeah we started
to support uh windows and python 3.9 so
actually now it works in any platform on
any uh any
python yeah as I said we implemented
hugging phase we also capable to work
with multi-language problems so it
doesn't mean that you need to translate
all your data set in the same language
and we as AWS we did we created
pre-builded packages for the sagemaker
which means that if you want to move it
in a production with a sagemaker we
already have a container so you just you
just you can just point to that
container and use it that that's it you
don't need to build a container by
yourself
um yes some more interesting things
adaptive early stopping
I'm just checking time okay so how
usually we're training so we need to
always specify when we want to stop a
training and usually that's like
um static value which you provide from
beginning like you say that if in 200
interaction my model haven't improved
just stop the training
from one side it's it's good approach
but from Another Side you have an
options to actually miss the best model
and you actually have a possibility that
you will waste the resources because
model haven't improved so we just we
created another approach we called
adaptive early stopping so we actually
recalculating that p-value b is patience
so we're just recalculating that value
every time when we find the new best
model there is a Formula it's it's
simple simple formula not something big
uh it's you can if you want you can take
a look on it
um there are there are several happy
parameters which is controlling that
formula but by default you can just
reuse values that we already you know
use by default in the library and the
idea is as I said we are continuously
recalculated every time when we find the
new best model we are recalculating that
p-value until we will complete the
training so yeah we're also doing
automatic feature pruning which means
we're doing feature selection
automatically for you we're using
semi-supervised inductive yeah
I'm just sorry for a rep I just have
five more minutes
um
yes we also use well for web models now
um that are much more and actually the
latest release one was uh less than a
month ago it was on 8th in July so what
we did we implemented clip so now you
can also use lip as part of the auto
glion and actually you can directly get
text to your text to embedded images to
text things in Audubon
um yeah we improved fine tuning we
started to add more data documentation
we enhanced teacher student distillation
so the idea is that you build a strong
model but it's too big you want to make
it smaller and that's the way way that's
a situation when you want to use teacher
student for model distillation to
distill the knowledge the smaller model
and as I said we started to use Time
series
uh yeah there is new Alto mm model so
actually the roadmap is available in the
GitHub as well you can take a look what
we are planning to work in the future
but as you can see we're doing releases
quite fast
um regarding how to bring it in the
production it's
um it's really easy are you allowed to
do whatever you want so if you want you
can train on the local computer if you
want you can train on a sage maker or
AWS easy tools or on any service that is
available in AWS and then when you want
to move it in the production again you
can deploy it in a day in your private
data center if you want you can bring
that model in sagemaker as I said we
have already pre-builded containers and
even if you want you can move it into
AWS Lambda if your model is not so big
and the latency is fine for you
um yeah so the short summary so today we
talked about two services and one open
source Library so the canvas is for a
business analysts who don't want who
want to use machine learning but don't
want to put handsome inside of machine
learning then there is a sagemaker
autopilot which is more designed for
data scientists who want to create first
prototype really fast and get let's say
first view on the problem with the data
and the and which algorithms works for
that problem and then we have an auto
glion which is
um the model the library which could
build your state-of-the-art
models and it works just with the three
lines of the code but inside there are
many interesting things are happening
and it's open source so you're allowed
to do whatever you want with it
so that's it
[Applause]
okay now it's time for questions if you
have any questions
yep
ah
quite impressive I have thank you
because I have some questions and some
reservations about
this model first of all about the tuning
uh are you using like biasing tuning or
what kind of tuning do you use to find
the best parameters firstly secondly
about the reservation part like
faster and
bigger models aren't always better
and that's my main reservation before
because people think that oh we have a
bigger model and with a lot of
parameters that should be better but as
you said like uh the complex models
aren't easy understandable and Implement
implementable and life isn't a Kegel
Championship because metrics have their
uh like metrics how their errors and
simpler models can be in the vicinity of
that error so there can be more
explainable and in that case better and
faster because XG boost model is very uh
hard to tune and is very time consumable
so that's the main reservation I have
but this is an interesting thing so uh
returning to my questions how is this
thing tuned
um if you're talking about the canvas
and autopilot we are using embedded
sagemaker tuning mechanism so there are
multiple
let's say methods strategist for
optimization if you're using those two
Services you're not allowed to select it
will be detected but for you actually by
default in autoglion you have some
control
um visited by something or so in a
sagemaker inside of the sagemaker we use
random search grid search by using
optimization we have all of them so you
can select if you're using sagemaker in
those Services something already
selected by default
um yeah regarding the second part of
your question I agree with you so big
model doesn't mean that it's always good
um and that's just the way how you can
train the model and see what results yes
I mean if you're if your data is really
fixed to the linear regression or not
linear regression but any type of simple
regression model and green there is no
reason to use autoglion uh lineal
Learners could do even better work than
monster that's true but it's that that's
come to another question what is your
data set and usually when we have a
problem and one we want to solve it we
are trying many different things and one
of the thing could be autobio okay one
more question if you've made so if I
have a data set that has a picture a
text description and let's say a lot of
parameters categories yeah uh can I use
uh let's say different models so let's
say XG boosts for several important
parameters regression for other nordics
node important parameters some other
models for text description and other
models for the picture and combine them
together
yeah yeah so that's idea of Auto glue on
for a multi-model data
I do not remember from the community is
it possible to select specific libraries
so the live your so by default we are
trying to select best models by
ourselves but if you want you have a
control on that so if you want to say
that for a tabular data you I want to
use xgboost you're allowed to say that
use extra boost and do nothing else if
you want to use specific library from a
hugging a specific model from a hanging
phase Zoom you're also allowed to do
that so you can just put the the name of
specific model and instead of using
default models or trying to select model
for you we'll just use what you
specified
so autoglion it looks like it's not a
black box yes there is a lot of
automation but it's fully under your
control there are many parameters how
you can tune so if you want you can even
provide hyper parameters for the models
inside of the stack you're also allowed
to do that
so yes by default it's simple to use
three lines of the code but there are
like hundreds of different tunes that
you can use
thank you
thank you for presentation I have a
question about models taking
when you stack different models
are they for the same task like for
example you have tabular data like you
are using like decision tree or random
Forest then you have output of data then
this output concatenates initial data
yes and other model is something like
tabular data modeler can be in a like
convolutional Network or something good
question yeah I didn't mention that
but
just just
where is the picture
the questions that are we using
same models on the on the first and
second layer uh yes exactly we're using
same models so model one is the same as
model one
yes
no we so we're using the same models but
we are retraining them because now they
use different data set because that
that's a bigger data set which is
concatenating from with the output of
previous models so
um let me paraphrase it so we are not we
are using the same algorithm on each
layer like model model one use the same
algorithm as this model one but the data
set is different so we are training this
one and this one independently
uh thank you and also second question uh
maybe I missed but I don't know do you
speak about the Amazon stage map maker
applications I am familiar with that but
didn't yet used I want to know when can
I use sagemaker
um so what is a yeah nothing yes I I
said that world several times but I
never said what is what is a sage maker
so inside of the
our stack of the services that I showed
you we also have I talked about the
little lower layer where it's just
infrastructure and I talked about a high
level where we have services but this is
a sage maker here's in the middle so
that's a platform and that platform
there is there is component to get
resources there is components to to you
know we we have a feature store we have
a clarify which is designed to find bias
to find to also create
um explainability things there is
notebooks so there is stage marker
Studio which is like
um our version of Jupiter lab so there
is a there is a component to train have
a parameters to deploy
um so yes you want you can deploy models
train it on the sagemaker you just say
deploy it and that's it will
automatically handle things like Auto
scaling monitoring
drift detection in an incoming data
drift detection in a model as well so
the sagemaker is a platform but
as I said if you want you can use it or
you could just use ec2 it's really up to
you in AWS we're not trying to force you
to use something Auto glion could be run
here just on virtual machine and auto
grid could be run in sagemaker as well
okay so in product deep link production
also is mentioned so it's popular to do
via Sage maker uh it's it depends I
could say that if you are looking for a
entire platform to start building
machine learning yes the sagemaker is a
brilliant it gives you the entire
pipeline so it's like from a data
exploration to the model deployment
model monitoring but in the same time
you probably have your own
uh you know tools that you love so
someone loves airflow and they want to
orchestrate it with airflow in this case
you could just use part of the sagemaker
actually airflow have a components with
a to control Sage maker so you can run
training jobs in a sage maker in
controlled by airflow it's also possible
so that's a that's a component it's like
a Lego bricks you can use whatever you
want
[Applause]